hi everyone here welcome back to yet
another episode of watching The Watchmen
we're done with Watchmen now and
unfortunately we have to deal with the
afterbirth of this series is being
Doomsday Clock it was originally
supposed to be a year long thing you
know twelve issues twelve months kind of
would have been cool wham bam would have
been finished by now I think around this
time but no we're about 75% 6% of the
way in on issue 7 def how's it going
yeah good man what's happening everyone
thanks for checking out the show I just
can't be on oh yeah literally like I
caught well I just read this like half
an hour before leaving it a little late
and I was just I didn't know where I was
in the narrative even when I got my
footing I couldn't give you know what I
mean like I just repeat it
yeah I've totally forgotten about it Tom
and then you text me last week saying
our doomsday clock speed released today
and I think I just replied [ __ ] yeah
that was it
just ruined my day Tom ruined my day
as always you know please subscribe
check out the old episodes as well that
we've gone through a send us an email
watching The Watchmen part at gmail calm
we don't really get well we already get
any emails we definitely don't get any
Doomsday Clock emails I don't really
want to do a recap or anything this
because I just can't really remember so
um let's get into it and as ever we'll
start with the covers the the lantern
with the blue moth yeah quite like it
foreshadowing obviously our our hero dr.
Manhattan and the green lanten you know
that draw the drawn to each other like a
moth to the flame Tom mm-hmm can you see
what they've done there yeah because
they do kind of get into the magnetic
pull about the the green light
I don't know I don't know why but
basically they have to use the Green
Lantern to pull don't mother don't do
they they use Bubastis yeah so what is
the Green Lantern for then don't really
know I know getting it myself um and I
only read Oh
today no it's it's not it's not clear
and we have lots of references to Green
Lantern in the star and this stuff again
I don't mind them doing this like you
know we we spoke at length about issue
four of Watchmen how you know it's one
of the greatest things ever created in
graphic novel form document hands origin
and one of the most sophisticated things
it does is telling this of temporal
narrative across many different
dimensions and they kind of a pit here
John's is aping in here giving us the
alan scott green lantern history um i
don't mind this but one of the things
that hit me reading these opening panels
especially there's just so many cuts to
TV and newsreaders and there's just so
much background being force-fed in your
gut yeah really does get convoluted at
one point and we'll talk about it as we
get into it because it's not whoa it's
just all over the shop really tom the
entire the entire comic book is just it
as a run it has very little focus every
single issue is just jumping about from
place to place and it just doesn't
really feel like there's a driving
narrative behind it to me it just feels
like a lot of spontaneous events um yeah
it's just yeah like Watchmen itself that
was set over like probably the space of
about three months I think whereas this
is like within 72 hours and it's just
cramming in so much information during
that time none of the characters
themselves really have time to reflect
on the events and like Dan and Laurie in
the original graphic novel they saw
reflected on what was happening in
brought a more relatable aspect to it
and that you could kind of see it
through a human's eyes and be taken in
by these grandiose events whereas
Doomsday Clock it's just happening so
quickly it's so convoluted and there's
not really a human side to it that we
can kind of view the events through I
don't think everyone's either mental or
has had this [ __ ] kicked out of them
there's not that grounding human side
which it was
what Watchmen did so well it took the
the supernatural and brought it down to
a human level whereas this just doesn't
have that side to it and it really
suffers because of it I think yeah it
doesn't the the Manhattan that we meet
in the intros is kind of absolutist you
know monarch of fate I kind of like the
idea of him sort of pushing the lantern
out the way and yeah in this reality the
guy dies and you know it's kinda it's
kind of noisy sort of I don't really
understand the whole dynasty the the
oriental gentleman I'm covering the lamp
is that just a sort of exists in time
yeah I think so basically the opening
discusses Alan Scott who was the first
Green Lantern and he was the Golden Age
one before they updated it without
Jordan in the earth to graphic novel run
from the new 52 which is an incredible
story by the way Alan Scott's actually
gay in that so a couple of years back
there was a huge thing for DC kind of
making one of their classic characters
gay and it is a great road light it
starts off pretty mad but it gets really
good as it goes on so definitely
definitely check that out if you what
the hell are you doing still reading
Doomsday Clock read a better comic but
anyway back to this so this is
continuing the storyline of Johnny
Thunder finding his ring yeah so I mean
it was released about seven months ago
the last issue a Korra member of that
well but anyway dr. Manhattan discusses
the history of the ring and how we
changed the timeline by killing Alan
Scott by moving the ring from the
clutches of his hand on the train crash
that started his origin story now credit
works too I do think Jon's
does a brilliant job of capturing dr.
Manhattan's voice and in this opening
page when I was reading their house
thinking hard it's great to see him
return and this introduction on just
this one page alone was probably the
most interested that have been in the
series since about issue one and
everyone's theory that the doctor you
know he left the Watchmen universe and
he traveled to the DC one that's
confirmed on this page
mm-hmm and I just wish they could have
kept up the quality of this page yeah
there's the dog they don't - you know
you're right it's 1985 I leave my world
for this one is awesome and it just sums
up that journey so powerfully I just
realizes well you can see in the [ __ ]
the Fanueil dusk or wherever that guy's
called who comes up later like yeah
though the worst like the absolute most
horrible take on the whole black Freya's
story in a story thing I just yet really
don't have never and I was I didn't
really know what was going on in the
plot I I was kind of thinking how did
you get out the asylum didn't the moth
break him out but I was like oh no that
wasn't in this world it was in the other
world and they was Saturn girl the
broken out of Arkham Asylum and you know
he was put into this prison but there
wasn't really any tension him breaking
out so that kind of defeats that purpose
and we get all these weird characters
kind of melded together and I don't know
none of them are that interesting no as
as we move through the old man in
particular the Hellfire at the back as
well as a little bit on the nose and
Archie arrives and then we get as
eventually before lots of TV screens I
mean all of the third page is exposition
exposition kind of a car number was the
last issue of the one before which are
quite liked where they showed the map of
all the metahumans and you was seeing
them in action and there's some
reference to Doom Patrol as well which
is pretty cool which is kind of DC's
oddball I think they're doing something
soon on the DC Universe app with that I
think Brendan Fraser's in it actually as
well yes but but yeah I mean what your
thoughts on this backdrop here the
context
it's just it's just nonsensical um and
it it's all over the shop and it really
took me out the booth could do who are
just being so sporadic and I think that
they could have summed up this entire
page with just a line of text that was
owed by one of the characters which just
needed to be something along the lines
of metahumans are on the rise and it's
slowly destroying the world but it's
just poorly handled and it really is
jarring and again it's that jumping
between characters thing that Watchmen
talk completely avoided it was very rare
that
watchman's switch perspective if each
issue picked its main character that was
going to be the center of that issue and
followed them that entire issue from
their perspective so we get great things
like Rorschach and being interrogated
but interviewed by Malcolm get dr.
Manhattan's perspective we get as him
indices as he travels the world whereas
this is just so it's so inconvenient and
just it's all over the place Tom I mean
we get our first viewing of Superman
since issue one but it's through a
screen and once again it just hammers
home how detached a lot of the
characters are from the actual run
itself and I watch this great thing last
night about how comedies more and more
are sort of relying on cameos and but
they're not good cameos they're just
like a celebrity showed up and that is
like the punchline
and now this kind of feels a bit like
that where it's they're just showing up
for the sake of showing up but it's not
it's got no substance to it it's got no
way and there's no real impact to it
because of it no you're completely right
yeah I've like LeBron James I think is
in some sick some rom-com or some [ __ ] I
watched and that felt very much just I
guess a modern-day Superman to a certain
extent but yeah they're on Archie we're
seeing Superman here in Libya called the
last true super in the world that sort
of idea there's just there's no momentum
to this plot there's nothing interesting
there's no I think pushing it forward
it's not gathering pace in the slightest
and we learned that Bubastis is this
weird compass thing for dr. Manhattan's
somehow yeah what the [ __ ] is this this
is a plot device that is happening
things do they not mention that it's
because own from the remnants but even
still it's like just this glowing cat
that leads you to this god I don't know
yeah it doesn't it's not the best is it
let's be honest guys even doomsday
defenders yeah I don't really know if he
can defend that to be honest
it's just weird throughout and it's a
really weird way to track dr. Manhattan
I you could have easily mentioned the
tachyons or something or his energy
signature just something but just using
Bubastis it's a bit I mean I did that
Bubastis is fine in the comic and they
they could have just brought them along
as like a pet is just a character like
as human dies likes to bring Bubastis
along with him but the fact that they
give him like this tracking device that
he can follow dr. Manhattan it's just
saying yeah yeah I mean even if they
just got like I don't know some DC
character that could join the team and
he can track man hang on though X you
know what would have been interesting if
they had a cloned Rorschach cuz he was
killed by dr. Manhattan wasn't he
so he could have had parts of his energy
signature and then we could have find
found out that Reggie was a clone or
something but the yeah it's just I don't
hold on
you could you could sit and think of a
million better things yes yeah I think
yeah I I agree and Ozzie sort of totes
off the ridiculousness the you know he's
incredulity you were led to Arkham
Asylum by Batman and locked up later
free bodies for new claims be here from
the future and then brought here
claiming to be a hero from the past and
not in in the hands of a skilled
storyteller that could be quite exciting
elements to a plot but here it's leaden
it's uninteresting we get the
transitions as we always do from our Z
smile into the watch what a what smile
gate by the way I know you're more on
MCU than me I saw this trending is it
some controversy her II don't know and
that's some Captain Marvel thing I don't
know what it is but I've seen I said
just because are you right yeah yeah I
dunno it is I think I do anyway but I
heard him mention it on a podcast the
other day base mark benedi image in it
which basically Captain Marvel doesn't
smile in the new Captain Marvel trailer
yeah I didn't even know it was it to be
honest no never I would never what your
trailer and be like
haven't smiled I hate this movie just to
notice it and I've totally forgotten
about it there till you mentioned that
it was a marvel right think the joke of
rocky have gotten the badge comedian is
being held hostage here again Joker
isn't written that well like he can be
such a fun canvas for people to express
themselves on like more I'm gonna
mention again all the book puns that he
does when he paralyzes Barbara Gordon in
Moore's voice I just I just love that
[ __ ] and I think the artworks cool here
from Frank's it's always nice to see
Joker's lair but again quite quite slow
plotting this whole sequence yeah and
this sort of derails the notion that one
of the three Joker's as the comedian mmm
so basically Tom if you didn't know
Batman in Darkseid war managed to get a
seat on the Mobius chair which is a
chair that allows whoever sits in it to
have all of the knowledge in the
universe and Batman when he was sitting
on it asked what the identity of the
Joker was and it replied there are three
and DC kind of used the whole joke
identity finally revealed pitch to get
everyone to buy rebirth issue one and
but in that they just said that there
were three I was a bit annoyed top I'm
not gonna lie because I was in Spain at
the time and I heard ah [ __ ] the big
Joker revealed his name and I bought the
the comic digitally for about a pound
Tom and I stupidly downloaded it over
him like over 4G in Spain right so it
cost about 50 pound which I was not
happy about especially the fact that
they didn't even reveal his name but now
because of that people sort of have
speculated that one of the Joker's could
be could have been the comedian and but
I think you know Tom between me you and
me I think a lot of us know that DC just
threw it in there with no real idea of
what they would do with it and after
about three years of rebirth we still
haven't had any resolution to it and I
think it's gonna be a completely drop
plotline so it's been cleared up here
that one of them is not the comedian
yeah
yeah it's a bit bit [ __ ] home it is a
big [ __ ] and it gets [ __ ] really you
know we have marionette here ploughing
comedian I mean I quite like when she
says what does she say says something
about like that's the you say that's the
bad bad that's the easy pain she says if
she looks me in the eyes which i think
is quite a dark line i quite like that
line but you know comedian taking the
strain there and then sort of you know
he's being held hostage to a certain
extent being interrogated and yeah again
these two characters haven't grown on me
at all somehow Batman standing up and
able to fight back even though is pretty
much decapitated in the last one yeah
which is a sort of Batman thing show up
and you will always get back on its feet
but how good is it Tom
so Batman manages to escape the torture
that the Joker and the mime and
marionette were inflicted on the
comedian um and just as it's getting
interesting we'll cut back to Oz human
Dyess so Batman just stands up somehow
runs off that's it that's it yeah
oh great no no and I mean we established
then the mind could fire actual bullets
because I thought that was like a joke
but he's actually firing something yeah
have we seen him fight something before
I think we have yeah I think in one of
the episode and one of the issues you
seen him like that it did actually have
a gun hmm and but it's just invisible
yeah which okay yeah yeah and don't put
it down because you'll you'll lose that
make sure you keep it on your hand at
all times
Bubastis is back say you know screeching
this little Tom Tom this little cat NAV
if you will leading us on again you know
we've kind of said what we need to say
about the arse well I think the eye is
very good you know Gary Frank is very
good at drawing faces the lantern is
passed over return back to Batman
there's more fighting between all of
them in this dusk
it is what it is really I think a lot of
the fighting your watchman was quite
lyrical and poetic and interesting if
nothing else original ways of combat
this is just a sort of a scuffle and we
see yet again that a deadly pincer rope
that she's throwing through and then
Joker just was sort of the lame happy to
see me flame fry so you're better than
that yeah that's really bad isn't it
yeah especially in the middle of the
fight it's just kind of like eye rolling
ly bad um yeah and I don't like it
so they arrived anyway the lads the main
the main thing that would be waiting for
4/7 issues which is the return of dr.
Manhattan I finally get to the middle
which is conveniently also where Joker
and the Batman and the comedian are and
they put that they used the green lanten
to create a pole
yeah to bring dr. Manhattan out yeah
yeah yeah anyway that is what happens
yet yeah do that and then there's a blue
dick in it Tom mm-hmm made me chuckle
cause they showed the show he's Dick Tom
and that's sort of what we've been
debating I don't know if you've seen all
the controversy recently surrounding
Batman's dick I haven't had I'm not
talking about Raman there I'm not
talking about Robin there I should have
led with that Tom but yeah Batman's dick
so basically DC I do and like a new
darker and grittier you know in quotes
and quotes comic line called I don't
know what the the line itself score but
there's a new Batman book called Batman
damned and in Batman number one the
showed Batman's dick I know you Google
in it right now to see it and but those
loads about its own panel yeah loads of
outcry from the internet and you know
we'll finally get a see Batman's dick
who know the Canon of Batman's dick Oh
another another pun there your Canon
okay anyway DC have retracted it and
said that they're removing the dick from
all future printings
yeah and it's quite funny because he has
our docs dick showing off he's a little
Smurf to the world oh yeah I'm just on
it now I'm on a Vox article titled
Batman's penis is in the comic book for
the first time ever but not for long
yeah it's now a collector's item okay so
you can sort of see it it's yeah hooded
I suppose yeah and then we get you know
what woman Watchmen sort of famous for
abstract paneling invention
experimentation with that I don't mind
sort of seeing you know the Blitzkrieg
to dr. Manhattan and then the panels
underneath I think they could have done
something a bit more interesting and I
think someone like Frank quietly for
example would have went a bit more to
town on this but yeah man hands back
this is this is the money shot yeah this
is a back but it's completely ruined for
me personally by the Joker screaming out
whoever you are put on some clothes for
God's sake or at least for mine haha no
I mean it's terrible table it's ruined
really a screenshot that when I saw it
and sent you it cuz it just wasn't good
Tom it really derailed that moment you
know
dr. Manhattan he's meant to be this
awesome figure like remember in the
movie when they were all sitting in the
canteen and then he just appears in the
middle of it floating above them
it's like looking up at a god and here
it's not it's not at all Tom it's [ __ ]
they really [ __ ] this up like like
this could have made them so much money
just couldn't be like an iconic story
they forget the fact about us Watchmen
fanboys getting pissed off that they're
bringing it back you know doesn't matter
but yeah he arrives on this chessboard
with a sort of satanic Crowley circle
around him and you know we we get a call
back to I guess the panel call back is
to when Manhattan arrives when it's
Laurie and Dan and then takes it makes
eggs are straight off and then goes to
Mars and it reminded me a little bit as
well
we'll get into this a bit later when
sort of Ozzy's motives are revealed
properly in the betrayal and the
realization of Laurie and and Reggie in
this so yeah we get the harking back and
Anne Hatton still looks like he's still
one of the most badass characters in
history but in graphic novel so it still
so cool to have him there hovering on
this this disk above this bubbling
forest and we get we finally get the
truth deaf about why he spared them
their pregnancy yeah he saw what the
child could have been mmm or something
hmm and he tells them that they're gonna
have another baby yeah
yeah I mean when I was reading it I just
thought it was handled really badly yeah
um it's sort of just delivered like an
offshoot like dr. manhattan's just saw
performing magic tricks like he's doing
some fortune-telling
but it doesn't really have the weight to
it that it should it just comes off like
it you'll be rich
I've read your fortune you're having a
baby thank you and then the audience
just sort of clap it doesn't really feel
like that impactful to me at least
anyway no I'm sure someone at IGN thinks
it's the best comic ever written yeah
and I mean just the fact that it's like
what are you talking about what did my
child do which child what do you mean
which child oh yes sometimes I forget
what's been and what will be it's like
do you know like isn't that your whole
character that you don't like I don't
know everything within your life yeah
you can view it all at once yeah like
yeah you don't forget stuff dr.
Manhattan no no i-i've made it he may
deliver things at the wrong time but he
doesn't say that you forget stuff no and
he doesn't error like a human would
error there he doesn't have any slips of
the tongue like that's just 9 no
repertoires very black-and-white yeah
he's very methodical and he's assuring
and he ret he never really changes his
mind he's very
finite and affirmative it's just very
he's never like Madonna he's not like us
on this podcast you know I mean he he
knows that everything is a fact
everything's said as a fact it's never
an opinion and it's never like oh yeah
what was yeah well as a kid again you
both work or the call and like what you
mean I've only got one
oh yeah it's forgot yeah sorry you got
one it's down the road you get the two
you know what I mean I'm just just
looking at the future now kids you're
gonna have a bunch of kids [ __ ] it up
ya know you learn as well that Adrian
doesn't have cancer this reveals boring
nothing hinged on this is enough any
impact for me at all and I struggle to
believe that that's what gave Reggie
motive as well that's what finds it
quite hollow for me
he's your action I don't find believable
at all yeah yeah but Tom did you like
how they're standing on a chessboard
yeah mental game of chess I can only
make certain predetermined path so I
suppose and I guess just some sort of
movement that Manhattan just walks in
certain directions I don't really know
but yeah this gets revealed I can't
really remember why I was he needed to
lie to get were shocked involved it was
too long ago but yeah parent is a big
deal breaker for old face yeah I don't
know why he would need a lie either be
honest you just be like look we need to
go save the world
yeah there's people outside my door now
they if they're allowed to come in
they're gonna destroy the universe we
need to go I know you don't like me
Rorschach I know you think I'm a bit of
a bad guy but come on gotta work
together
have you seen x-men to Tom god-like
cinema when I was very young yeah
Magneto and Professor X they have to
work together you know it's about
fighting the greater bad hmm so yeah the
cancer thing was pointless yep and it's
not really been touched upon that much
to the
where it feels like a big plot point it
was just sort of like on an x-ray in the
background an occasion you say I ever
cancer and because cancer was a big plot
device in Watchmen as well it just sort
of fades into that whole broth and I
don't think it has much impact beyond
that you know it's great to see Reggie's
dad here obviously the home and the
[ __ ] Rorschach test scenes in the
prison are so good like he's just making
me look back and I love how we see him
from the back which I think's the final
scene of the abyss gazes also as he's
looking into the into the ink lot which
is so so good and again Ozzy sharing
about his parents dying
they died despising one another alone I
really know how he knows that but yeah
you wouldn't know that there's no no way
yeah they I don't even know why you
would take interest in Malcolm to be
honest and without like knowing that
he's a main character that there's no
absolutely no reason why would you would
like surely would take as much interest
in like a prison guard or something
yeah it doesn't really make any sense
but I'll let it pass Tom it's comics
yeah I go yeah but what I do like is
that Rorschach it's sort of the route
you know comes to the realization that
he's a bit of an idiot I mean you saw of
Rorschach in this one he's left at his
most vulnerable and he seems a bit
mental and what I want to see is his
Redemption is arc of redemption I'm
quite interested in seeing that down the
line
I think Rorschach - probably is the most
interesting character in this book so
I'll say we'll say something nice Tom I
don't know how long we've been going on
it's been nearly half an hour I'll say
my first nice thing I'm still interested
in Rorschach okay so there you have a
listeners but yeah you starting really a
convoy just interested in but I know
it's positive yeah yeah I mean I just I
just wish we could I just wish I had the
hardback I'll just finish the whole
thing tonight yeah
break it down and it's just like what's
being being drip fed this but yeah I
mean Reggie's yeah he's fine um so we
see the sort of world you know slowly
bubbling over here um what is this red
panel where it says I saw a vision of
the most hopeful among them heading
towards me now hopeless why is that
showing that Superman isn't it is that
Superman always that look he's cape or
something um it looks like his eyebrow
is I in his nostril to me right okay
okay can you say that I can't actually
no no I can't see that top lines his
eyebrow and below that his eye closed
eyes closed
oh yeah yeah I see it no yeah and I
think it looks a little bit similar to
when marionette like blinds people was
like that I remember that sequence in
the alleyway where she comes at a guy
with the string then it goes all red and
black but yeah yeah actually yeah I can
see it now that's interesting okay and
then you know I guess these are sort of
similar to the dog Keene Act stuff in
Watchmen as well these sort of crowd
scenes and then we get some the Fanny
awesome the Fanueil does what is this
about I don't know I don't know dr.
Manhattan transports them to the theater
where we see a black and white movie
playing which is the the Nathaniel dusk
thing and I just hope this isn't the big
end of that because it's just a terrible
inclusion and I honestly I don't really
know what I like why they went there no
it's just don't get at all no no I don't
I think it's not clear over and you know
the characters don't really understand
why he brought them there over maybe
it'll make sense maybe yeah maybe down
the line they'll be like some big reveal
oh my god they've said this since issue
one but I would say Karla Coleman's head
hits the floor that's what he talks
about you see that yeah well that means
yet no no and yeah I just I just don't
like this obscurities I'm like it's like
you know rare the the game company are
often insulted for this where they set
something up really
you have to go all the way back to get
it and then it's like I don't know like
some of that stuff's great fill in the
blanks is sometimes really fun it can
make enliven a story but in this case
not so far you know we get more fights
you're you're still wearing the mask of
the man who destroyed your father is a
nice idea here and Ozzie always has a
real like stinging thing to say about to
beat the [ __ ] out of him yeah you like
that but yeah I mean fights happen here
Batman gets shocked in the head Ozzy's
getting punched to death Joker's getting
punched back and forth back and forth
yeah I do quite like this bit and I did
think that Ross I could kill the Joker
yeah and he gets his big red smile on
his face and when I was reading that
though it didn't feel impactful because
obviously the joke has died about seven
million times so I knew this wouldn't
hold much way and basically we then find
out that the Joker isn't dead and it's
Rorschach who's actually dead
like his persona like a Star Wars thing
whether like Anakin Skywalker was killed
by Darth Vader
um which it didn't really have the
impact with me in all honesty but
basically the plans over it all went to
[ __ ] white gets angry he hits a woman it
just feels like a chaotic mess with no
real end at this point I was I was
rolling my eyes a bit Tom I was wrong my
eyes quite a lot for this bit yeah me
too me too I mean yeah my my sockets
were sore by the time I was done really
you know we move through we get Saturn
girl here everyone's descending upon
Archie the old man gets kicked in the
face by Ozzy Ozzy still has a plan
apparently even though he yeah that's
the plan just went to [ __ ] why'd you
kick them people and hit them toy don't
I guess he just sort of in a you know
post rage I don't really know his motive
that he never really seemed violent in
Watchmen even when like he's at carnac
and they're Rorschach and night-owl are
fighting him
doesn't seem violent he's just seems
like he's so just blocking because it
doesn't want to get hurt he's up her but
he never at no point does you know fight
throw the first punch in any Watchmen no
it's always he's put into it he's backed
into a corner and he's just blocking and
striking and disabling people he's never
on the offensive he's always on the
defensive except for when he sets off
the bombs so for him to go into Archie
and punch a woman in the face and kick
an old man just seems out of character
yeah yeah I guess it's supposed to make
us feel for these characters to an
extent but they're so shallow and
uninteresting that I don't you know I'm
not there we get lots of snapshots on
the next page
lots of world-building black Adam is
entering Jerusalem apparently
something's being posted to Lois Lane I
guess in a sort of new frontiersman
correspondence there the chess imagery
persists Manhattan touching down on Mars
all these fingers coexisting maybe
something from the Fanueil dusk I'm not
quite sure what that is now I do like
this section I have to say I think this
is pretty cool actually the the furthest
he can see in the future is Superman
running a team then he sees nothing
beyond that
yeah so we'll get a tease of Superman
fighting dr. Manhattan everything goes
black and he says he doesn't know if
it's the end of his life finally or if
it's him just strong the universe
spoiler alert Tom it's him dying because
no way
our DC ending this lucrative cash curl
that they've built up for the last day
he is yeah but we'll say Tom I don't
know how dr. Manhattan just doesn't wipe
Superman out to be honest no I don't
know how a punch is gonna affect dr.
Manhattan either he doesn't seem like
he's that tangible yeah I don't
understand what punching him would do no
no cos gangs rebuild his intrinsic
fields carne so it's like what is he
yeah I mean yeah it's yeah it's fine
it's a punch as well just uh punch it
it's the best way to solve it solve any
problem tell them just by punching it
remember in Watchmen when like the Tri
assault the the wars by setting up this
elaborate plan that would trick people
into uniting you know one nation in
order to fight each other no all wrong
Tom they should've just for their
problems by punching them we get the
photo which I guess brings us back full
circle to the fourth issue the
incredible photo which we went deep on
in the issue in danger to be a classic
more within the frame of the paper
itself I think there's a balloon
floating off into nothing as you see
someone's hand Janey Slater of course I
don't know again I don't really know
what this photos here why it's just sort
of flying around in the dress but
remember Watchmen tom is he why is he
landing where he landed before and then
I guess the photo hasn't moved since
yeah maybe because it did drop it didn't
he so yeah that's what it's employing
that's very good then yeah kept that
consistent come I mean there might not
have kept the characters consistent
there might not have gave a compelling
story but at least they've got the
position of that photograph right it's
just the fact again that they have the
cause asleep I'll sleep good tonight Tom
knowing that continue
who the hell is our I'm just cooling a R
Buckminster Fuller okay so he was an
American architect and an inventor okay
so he was some sort of you know whiz kid
back in the day not as we heard him
myself
seeing is believing is a blind spot in
man's vision this is the closing quote
here and I mean I guess that's pointing
to the imperceptible 'ti of certain
things right some subatomic things as
opposed to a certain extent and perhaps
we shouldn't trust what our eyes capture
yeah maybe I don't know Tom what's going
on it was a lot of crap that was that
was a terrible issue of comics a waste
of everyone's time
cluding our listeners but yeah there we
go issue seven and even the back stuff
which I know you don't really read death
and a quick glance through I quite you
you can see the Bubastis Tory though
it's quite a nice effect yeah I did like
that actually had to read this one and
it talks about the backstory of new
Bubastis and so the death of the
original and then the cloning and yeah
it's nice
the the figures is the best thing yeah
and it's you can tell that bite clearly
hung up on the death of this cat and to
me it you know it does some nice
painting of the backstory like when
awesome and I said goodbye old friend
when he killed Bubastis I thought he was
talking about dr. Manhattan but clearly
he was talking about the cat and
basically it sets up Bubastis in
Manhattan and it talks about the cat
rebuilding itself and then appearing
near the fence and stuff yeah not sure
about where doesn't yeah yeah again just
I mean walking back hulking back but
that was Doomsday Clock issue seven
we still got [ __ ] five left yet five
issues left
yeah he's as Christ got an eight point
eight and IG end on IGN is just baffling
isn't it just this show they really over
eight everything I mean they just
they're clearly in the pocket you know
but are definitely but then most of
these comic book websites seem to love
this so I just yeah enjoy it look I'm
not gonna hate but I just are everything
is very good yeah since IGN played your
eyes a lot of reviews I'm gonna
plagiarize one of them come Doomsday
Clock seven gives the series an
adrenaline boost as dr. Manhattan
finally emerges from hiding and I don't
know what the hell these people are
reading Tom because that was no
adrenaline boost for me he showed up
talk to them and then [ __ ] off yeah I
don't know what their big shot in the
arm was there yeah it's like apparently
he gets punched just oh god I'm pumped
now oh wow
great writing guy
yeah cannot wait for this carpet roundup
gave it an eight point six out of ten
fortress of solitude give it a 7.5
I mean user rating nine point five on
comic book roundup getting tens all over
the place of I'll read or read big a
read em geek dad's little review of it
this is the issue I've been waiting for
since Doomsday Clock began combining the
whip-smart writing with the plot
advancement I've been waiting for I what
plot advancement happened Tom what has
moved forward in the plot they're
actually back at square one if anything
you're right there then ominous one here
from Steve J Ray I'm looking forward to
the future if there actually is one well
well there's not Tom if it's more [ __ ]
like this to be honest with you yeah
yeah it was a little crap and we'll be
back in two months or so tackle issue
nine as ever please people go back check
out our other discussions check out what
we spoke to mr. J Higgs as well that was
a crazy episode we've got some comments
as well Tom I just got one from Eric
punt Doomsday Clock is so boring and so
superficial it is a shame that DC has
the arrogance to think that they can
make a sequel of the masterpiece
Watchmen I will stop reading this
Doomsday Clock from now on but please
don't stop listening though Eric PS your
Watchmen analysis is are masterful
thanks a lot
is it analysis or analysis is it
analyses maybe I don't know
Josh will cool he comments quite a lot
Tom so it's good that he's still on
board with us especially after slugging
it off I'm still enjoying the book and I
said to Josh if you're listening please
please reply I've been waiting for three
months I know you've you've left me
unread I said what do you like about it
but I didn't get reply
so it would be good to see what people
enjoy about this book because I can't
really find anything
maybe it's because I'm sat with you Tom
and you're a negative Nancy
I suppose so Ivy I just it's it's called
taste it's like it's like I'm gushing
Lee positive about good stuff and it's
like I just can't I just I just can't
justify this I'm afraid I just it's it's
yeah I think it's a load of crap really
I think I think it's a failure I think
it's a failure yeah it feels I really
should have like revitalized the comic
book industry no I mean the return of
Watchmen the Watchmen and DC Universe is
coming together and it just at this
point feels like a non-event it reminds
me sort of the The Dark Knight Returns 3
mm which how so invested like every two
months I was gone the comic shop to see
if they had it in and just got delayed
so much in Seoul that will happen that
by the end of it didn't care and it is
like I have went back and read it as a
trade-in it is a good book but this
doesn't feel like it's even up to that
level to be honest so don't know what
they're gonna do Tom no but you know
we'll be here to recap and decorate and
to inform and yeah I mean as always it's
boring isn't it literally bringing up
the same points every issue I know I
don't know how many times I can say this
is going nowhere yeah and it's jumping
about from seeing the scene with no real
perspective and there's nothing to
really ground it there's no characters I
like in it Tom even Batman I don't know
what he is it's just a nonentity in this
run there's nothing I like yeah it's
it's a seeming disappointment but you
know hopefully if you [ __ ] with the show
you down for the analyses anyway you
know subscribe to all our channels and
all that good stuff yeah make sure you
subscribe to me guys
I care about these days just hit 5000
subscribers Tom I've tell you what I've
just hit five thousand two hundred and
twenty seven so that number is growing
every day it'll be six thousand soon and
then I can retire and stop doing this
[ __ ] how many subscribers do I need till
I can quit Tom laughs well what to stop
doing Doomsday Clock let's say five
thousand two hundred and fifty I think
when it gets to that number we can stop
doing it I think it might hit oh wow if
I hear right now yeah hopefully
hopefully
well I'm emailing by the time you're
listening to this guy's you just go and
look at my subscribers and if we passed
that number then it's over I like to
thank youse all for taking the time to
listen take care good night well
everyone watching The Watchmen pod at
gmail.com send us a message over there
we'll get to that on the next issue are
you still reading doomsday [ __ ] as Eric
Ferguson always mentions it as but yeah
death this has been a treat regardless
thank you much
[Music]